let's talk about the pros and cons of
carbo loading
before a sporting event so a lot of
athletes are doing this especially for
endurance type sports that involve over
90 minutes and so they might carbo-load
one to four days before this event using
all sorts of carbs like sugar
these gels that many times have
maltodextrin and dextrin which is a
synthetic sugar
cliff bars or i think they have like
these cliff gel packs energy bars so the
goal is to
beef up the glycogen reserve in the
muscle and the liver now glycogen is
stored glucose molecules and so the way
that it works is that the glycogen
stored in your muscle actually provides
the muscle with glucose and glycogen
that is stored in the liver provides the
blood with glucose as well as the brain
and there's a big difference between the
capacity you can store glucose in the
liver versus the muscle
in the liver it's only like 100 grams
and the muscle it's 500 grams and so the
reason why people doing this is just to
go longer without fatigue but if you
look at the type of fuel that they're
running on which is glucose because
they're not fat adapted there's a pretty
big limited capacity
because when you're talking about
glycogen stored sugar
it's only like maybe
17 100 calories of stored glucose maybe
up to 19
uh maybe 2 000 calories at the very most
of store glucose so that would provide
energy
roughly about 90 to 120 minutes at the
most whereas if you were fat adapted
it's virtually unlimited as far as the
amount of calories that you can use as
energy even someone that is not
overweight has about a hundred thousand
calories of stored energy as their fat
versus like 1700
calories so there's a huge difference
and so more and more athletes are
becoming fat adapted because they're
finding
it gives them the unfair advantage
because their ability to tap into this
reserve that they didn't have when they
weren't fat adapted so one disadvantage
of carbo loading is limited capacity
number two you eventually hit the wall
that's that's called bunk where you run
out of sugar and now you're hypoglycemic
and so you feel weak you feel exhausted
mentally and physically and this forces
you to
drink and eat sugar
during the exercise spout but i remember
when i was in my 20s when i was doing a
lot of sugar i was exercising i would
hit that wall and my legs literally
would not move so i know what that feels
like so i would just have some more
sugar and keep going all right so number
one limited capacity two you hit the
wall
three there's a lot of gas bloating
abdominal pain when you do this carbo
loading because you're having excessive
amount of fermentation and so they're
just going to go to town and you're
going to start getting excess
fermentation in your gut all right next
one is
diarrhea that's one of the side effects
now what is the problem with diarrhea
well
it's a big problem because of
dehydration you're going to lose your
fluids and electrolytes including
potassium magnesium calcium as well as
sodium so it's very very dangerous to do
any type of sporting event after you
have diarrhea because these electrolytes
feed your heart and so if you're going
to do some type of endurance exercise
with
maybe subclinical amounts of
key electrolytes
you're going to be at risk all right
number five
fluid retention
when you carbon load you hold water for
every one molecule of glucose you hold
between three to four molecules of water
so potentially you're going to be
holding on to about two and a half
kilograms or 5.5 pounds of actual water
on your body all right and then you have
number six
blood pressure so when you're doing
carbs you're retaining sodium and you're
retaining fluid and your blood pressure
potentially could go up now that can
also be because of another thing i'm
going to talk about when you consume
that much refined carb as sugar you're
going to deplete potassium
magnesium and other electrolytes so the
imbalance of sodium retention versus
potassium deficiency can definitely set
you up for higher blood pressure all
right number seven
and this is one of the things that i
want to mention as far as a a plus point
or a positive thing or a
pro as far as
elite athletes elite athletes have three
times the insulin sensitivity than
non-athletes and i'm talking about elite
athletes apparently they don't seem to
get the severity of insulin resistance
and so if you're going to consume all
this sugar right you're going to raise
insulin one big danger of that is
insulin resistance so apparently being a
elite athlete counters this insulin
resistance so that would be one benefit
and so far i'm only finding this one
benefit so exercise does counter insulin
resistance and insulin resistance is
really part of a pre-diabetic condition
and the study that i'm quoting
really has only to do with elite
athletes not someone that is less than
that or just exercising maybe on a
regular basis okay and they're doing
carbo-loading i'm talking about elite
athletes all right number eight
inflammation and leaky gut all that
sugar is very oxidating it can affect
the eyes the heart the kidneys the
nerves and it can keep your body in a
state of
inflammation so
one thing we don't want when we're
competing is more joint inflammation
or muscle inflammation all right and
number nine and this is something that's
not very known
when you consume
refined carbohydrates as carbo-loading
you're going to deplete a lot of
potassium
b1
magnesium
and even calcium and these minerals and
vitamins act as antioxidants to counter
uh some of the complications that occur
when your blood sugar goes higher and
the more carbs that you need the more b1
you need and there's a lot of symptoms
that go along
a b1 deficiency one would be a buildup
of lactic acid okay one thing you don't
want with exercise is excessive amount
of lactic acid which is kind of a
byproduct of glucose metabolism so when
you're exercising a lot using a lot of
energy and a lot of carbo-loading
without that b1
there's a whole series of things that
can happen
one lactic acidosis two neuritis nerve
pain three a lot of cognitive problems
especially with stress and anxiety and
so if someone was going to be
carbo-loading they should be also b1
loading as well as well as potassium
loading magnesium loading and having
some calcium as well not that i
recommend carbo-loading but if you're
going to do it you better make sure you
take these other factors now potassium
is really important in regulating the
heartbeat it's important in generating
energy and so is magnesium magnesium is
necessary to make atp and so without
these electrolytes you're just not going
to have the efficiency to make the
quantity of energy that you really need
when competing and so i'm not even
talking about just supplying the heart
with electrolytes i'm talking about
making energy in general so based on all
these points i really don't think
carbo-loading
is going to be worth that one little
benefit of improving insulin resistance
and on that note i think the best next
video for you to watch is my video on
vitamin b1 check it out it's actually
quite interesting
you